- It's a good job that I am
going to the gym tonight.
(hip hop style music)
- Is this is just a big cookie?
- It's like a cheese ball or something.
- Very hard in texture.
- It's sort of like flakey.
- Ooo, coconuts!
Oh.
These are doughy.
- It's not as sweet.
- Maybe it would be good if
you like dunked it in tea
or hot chocolate or something like that,
to make it a wee bit softer.
- It's actually really good.
- [Girl 1] Oh, is this moon cake?
- This is from like Taiwan, right?
- It doesn't smell
recognizable to me at all.
- Oh, it reminds me of
like a fig or something.
- Mmm.
- Mmm!
You know, don't eat
this on the first date.
- I'm still like chewing the filling.
It got stuck in my teeth.
- This reminds me of food we used to
eat back home in Singapore.
- It tastes like a Fig Newton
but like, way nicer.
- [Girl 2] Well, I really
hope this is not a real egg.
- This is Asian.
- This is like from China,
but China is really big.
- Oh yeah, I can see the base,
it's definitely like a pastry type thing.
- From where I'm from,
we don't eat like pastries that has like,
a lot of thin layers of crust.
- I'm a tough Scots woman,
I can handle this.
(crust crumbling)
- No.
- This doesn't taste that sweet,
for a dessert.
- It just tastes like a giant
ball of chocolate inside.
- That was definitely an egg!
- I am making a very big mess.
- This looks delicious!
- It's very beautifully done.
- Frosting and sponge
cake and fruit inside.
- This, definitely reminds
me of birthday cakes
that I've had as a child
growing up in Scotland.
- Mmm!
- Look at that green icing.
- Ooo! There's marzipan in this.
- I've never seen marzipan
anywhere but England.
- I don't like marzipan.
- Very, very sweet.
- Well this looks rather unappetizing,
let's be honest.
- It doesn't look dessert to me.
(sniffing deeply)
- Cinnamon?
- It has like a little bit fruit smell
but I can't tell what it is.
- Almost candy.
- It looks like a healthy toffee
because it has sesame seeds on it.
- But, it could be yummy.
Oh, God, okay.
Oh, it's really good.
(laughs)
Mmm, I like this a lot!
- Watermelon.
- I would see myself
eating this by the beach.
- Cinnamon and gooey things.
- The watermelon gave like
a very refreshing taste.
- These were really good desserts.
I feel like the US has
to step up their game.
(funky instrumental music)
- [Voiceover] Oh yes!